Hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to DOOM
Now I have been playing this game on my own
This is still the savegame i was playing before, I'm not gonna start it over again, I have made to much progress
But I have realized that I need to be much, much more observative about my enviroment
and the things that I find in the area around me
Like over here!
If I look there's a lever right here
and one of the things that I have not been seeing and probably you guys
have been really on my ass about, then I'm sorry but I'm trying my best!
Is the secret levels
Oh is this gonna kill me?
Oh shit...
I probably should have rethought this
*Quick desperate mating call*
Fuck! God Dammit! Aaah why am I starting it of like this!?
I could've double jumped at the bottom down there
That would've been much smarter!
Apparantly I'm not like an actual Halo dude, I can't fall from orbit and still survive
So lets just back up a couple steps and restart this
Okay! take twaaaaaaaaaaah!
Or...  take... is twa three? twa is three! sorry. Take two!
HARBLUEFF
Okay... so now I'm gonna actually intelligently ride this down... (I was about to fall there)
And then we're going to find one of the classic map areas.
And one of the cool things about this game is how much it pays respect to the original DOOM
and that's something that I like a lot, because
there's a lot of history to be gleaned,
gleaned is an awesome word that I havent used in a long time
but there's a lot to be GLEANED from the
NO!
LEMME IN
HUAAAH ok
but there's a lot to be gleaned from like this environment
and the old stuff
and what this'll do, is it'll unlock a game
er, er a...
a level from the original DOOM, but in this game engine
and its really disturbing because the old school doom like
they're all just... sprites that have one direction they face and i always thought it was weird
they always face me
*GASP* i was recently um.... I had to look up some more information
about the original DOOM and it totally
didnt connect that i have done
an episode of did you know gaming about DOOM
*impression of a little girl* DONT SEAL ME IN OH GOD
Aw SHIT I almost got SQUOOSHED
i dont wanna get squooshed, let me through
BUDDY BOO
Alright, but I actually did an episode of did you know gaming
about DOOM and I totally forgot that I did that
so it was really cool to see some history about it and look up some videos
and look up some videos about how the original doom came about
and a lot of you guys probably don't actually...
uh...
pay much attention to how game engines are developed
but back then this was actually
a crowning achievement of game design
Because- I didn't even realize this
The original DOOM
was not actually 3D
And you may be going like:
"Oh! Of course, it's 3D! What're you talkin' about?"
But no! It's actually...
A modified representation
Of a 2D... Top-down shooter
Which BLEW my MIND!
You HAVE to watch the video about it, because
Wolfenstein was made in the same way
That's easy to understand how it was a top-down shooter
Considering, all the walls were exactly the same height
It was just uh...
Uh, uh 3D representation of 2D pixelated art
And that's fascinating the way that that is
But- just everything else that went into DOOM
and making DOOM
oh shit...
Making D- Uh, okay!
HERP!
Making DOOM what it is, is...
Literally astonishing, like-
the amount of work they put into that sorta stuff
is, incredible
and the cleverness of the programming
Because, the REASON
Back then
when DOOM was originally released
computers were not
POWERFUL enough
At least in a general sense for everybody
Home, everybody's comptter
It was not powerful enough to be able to do 3D
In real-time
So they had to come up with cleverer, like- WAYS to cheat it out.
Oh, I thought that guy was gonna get ZAPPED
HER BERP BLERGSKY
'Scuze me
Sorry
I'm sorry
Oh, wait, did I miss something?
Ooo, I mighta missed something
Did I miss...?
uh...
I've been trying to be good about checking for these things
but I feel like I might have missed something...?
Maybe, maybe not
Oh well, we'll find out later
I'm trying to be better about the collectables, but-
I, I-I REALLY, REALLY, am trying to be better about collectables and secrets and stuff-
But...
I, w-wvi-ig-it's a trade-off
I wanna show you guys everything I CAN
But at the same time...
I...Can't always be stopping to look around and shopping around and-
And checking every nook and cranny for everything that I have, because-
it wastes a lot of TIME and...
I wanna get through to the end of this game
Because it IS a 16 hour game, so...
*breath*
The best I'm gonna be able to do
Is keeping an eye out
I've got the thing where- I know what it is now.
The compass, literally that thing at the top
It'll vibrate when...
AAH!
WHY DID I ASS-PLODE!?
*prepubescent scream*
It better not put me ball the way back down at the bottom
the son of a BITCH!
WHAT THE FUUUUUUUUU-
UUUUUUUUUUUU-Okay, we're fine.
Hebbeda habbeda
A'ight, just don't do that again.
Egh...
Well, that's an interesting sound. Is that zappy-zappy in my ear?
Huablfft
Oh no, he's dead!
Wow, okay
That was bizarre
also
I realize the super shotgun is, like-
INCREDIBLY badass
more than you usually need for these types of enemies.
Wait...
I...Yeah, over here
More than you usually need for these types of enemies, but-
The super shotgun...
With quad-damage
Can one-shot a MANCUBUS
which is the big FLABBY fucker.
Nyeh, nyeh
I also realized that this. The pistol. The charge chop for the pistol.
Is actually pretty damn powerful.
Like, is legit. Like 100% legit. It can wipe out some people
The only thing that is not powerful is the pittlely little.
like, peashooter you got in teh front
You gotta charge it up because if you dont
charge it up, ITAINTWORTHSHIIETT
Okay, am I suppose to? oh
Oooohhhh I wasn't suppose to- ooookay
I got it, I got it, I got it.
I got it! I wasn't suppose to do anything.
It seems like there'd be a secret around here.
But I'm not 100% suuuure.
I feel like I'm close to a secret.
Oh wait,
there's something over there.
HELLO!
HIIIII!!
WELCOME TO THE PARTY! Don't run away from me!
*Killing sounds?*
Have I done all the objectives on this-(nyuong)
Quad damage, net breaker, glory Imp from behind.
Waah, didn't do that one so if I find some imps I'll do it to them but
Super shotgun, boink-wah that was not super shot gun that was a god damn rocket launcher.
Whoopsies
Oh well, who's counting? nyeh neyh
There we go
Hey how you, boink, sorry.
See it's sooo powerful it's a god damn street sweeper.
Alright theres's something over there I saw on the map but
Oh-- oh thats the pulsation, it pulsates yellow.
ahh... so that is a secret, ok, so I imagine--